so I am here with Sharon and Shipka from
the chilling Adventures of Sabrina
indeed all right so I'm gonna ask you a
couple questions well we are here
tonight celebrating kids what's the best
part about being a kid oh my god just
figuring out who you are it's a very fun
journey okay who is your celebrity I
know growing up and did you ever get to
meet them I mean I was a big a pretty
big zack & cody fan and I know dylan and
Cole now so I'm making my like
seven-year-old self really proud the
Kitchener woods is all about slime and I
love your outfit but thank you are you
prepared to get slimed
I mean I'm as ready as I can be I mean
who's ever ready to get slimed but if it
happens it happens I'm willing to accept
it yeah we just got a glimpse of part
two of Sabrina the first part was pretty
dark how spooky does it get way darker
like like it ramps up by like a hundred
Melissa Joan Hart is gonna be on a new
Netflix show can we see her pop-up in
future seasons
I mean I would love that as she's down
I'm down right yeah thank you so much I
love a pleasure I loved you in the show
thank you so much as - yeah thank you
see you in there